pour
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du sky échos le récit de
la vie des acteurs économiques du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes sur le site de airbus
defense and space à elancourt devant
l'entreprise j'ai d é simulation c'est
une filiale du fonds de l'armement
français
mbd à et cette société est spécialisée
dans la conception de simulateurs de tir
destinés aux forces armées des
technologies de pointe qui plonge les
soldats dans des conditions réelles lors
de leurs entraînements c'est ce que vous
découvrirez dans ce 20e numéro du sky
échos le centre commercial espace saint
quentin un nouveau gestionnaire avec à
la clé une nouvelle stratégie et des
enseignes qui vont arriver sur ce site
c'est une entreprise spécialisée dans la
fabrication de simulateurs de tir
destine à l'entraînement des forces
armées découverte de gdx simulation
filiale du groupe
mbd a installé à elancourt enfin focus
sur l'entrepreneuriat étudiant lui vs qu
accompagne des projets de création
d'entreprise exemple avec la marque
vilain canard on commence ce sky aequo
avec le nouveau propriétaire de l'espace
saint quentin le groupe alliance vient
d'acquérir à 100% le centre commercial
de montigny le bretonneux
il a racheté les parts du groupe
hammerson avec qui il partage et la
propriété il a confié la gestion à
altarea commerce avec une ambition
renforcer l'attractivité de ce centre
commercial les détails avec stéphane
franck le directeur de la gestion
locative sur des images des länder
sinoquet
[Musique]
un actif très intéressant puisqu'il a
effectivement beaucoup de fondamentaux
très intéressant il a un bassin d'emploi
très important 145 mille emplois sur la
zone sur seize mille entreprises des
universités écoles un centre de loisirs
et des activités loisirs très importante
avec un cinéma avec effectivement un
théâtre également dans la bande dans la
zone on a également une un enjeu de
diversification de l'offre sur des
activités qui manquent un peu de niveau
du site
je pense notamment à la décoration à
l'équipement de la maison à
l'ameublement
on parlera également de services qui
sont importants services à la personne
n'est pas qu on a déjà un centre médical
sur la zone mais il faut continuer à
offrir d'autres services à la clientèle
et la population qui vit le site au
quotidien
[Musique]
j'ai d é simulation est une entreprise
située à elancourt développement de
logiciels fabrication de systèmes
électroniques ou encore assemblage de
produits tout cela pour fabriquer des
simulateurs destinés à l'entraînement
des forces armées
c'est l'activité de la soixantaine de
salariés sur site et pour en parler nous
sommes avec le directeur général de ge
et des dissimulations francis darveau
bonjour bonjour vous existez depuis 70
ans donc comment a évolué votre activité
alors je n'étais pas là au début de
l'activité en dérive années 1950 la
société a commencé par faire des
activités liées aux valeurs tournant du
l'activité initié le nom initial de gier
avions d'oran dont on fait différentes
activités dans la chimie dans la simili
dans l'électronique les activités autres
que l'électronique ont été vendus avant
les années 2000 la société a été reprise
en 1996 par le groupe aérospatial dans
le cadre des activités hostiles qui
nécessitent des simulateurs avec des
traitements de données un peu
confidentiel et la troisième étape pour
résumer la vie de l'entreprise
c'est que mba a racheté
la propriété la société en 2000 le fin
pour constituer un grand pôle européen
de simulation service défense
alors je le disais un cd simulateur qui
sont destinés à l'entraînement des
forces armées
concrètement comment ça se passe nous
sommes le premier partenaire de l'armée
de terre française pour la préparation
opérationnelle des forces avant les
autres textes
ce sont des simulateurs qui sont
déployés sur le terrain qu'ils font qui
nous permettent de faire de la guerre
électronique au service des forces en
fonction de la doctrine en simulant en
temps réel en environnement réel les
manoeuvres de combat nous sommes le
dernier stade d'entraînement avant le
départ en opex décès quelle est la
stratégie de votre entreprise du coup la
stratégie de notre entreprise c'est
d'abord d'être au service des forces
pour la préparation opérationnelle comme
je voulais indiqué c'est d'être un
acteur global sur l'assimilation
puisqu'aujourd'hui nous simulons dans
notre domaine d'excellence à peu près
l'ensemble des armes de le terrain c'est
à dire que sa part du fantassin ça passe
par les blindés notamment du programme
scorpion et ça va aussi évidemment vers
les missiles la troisième dimension dans
le cadre du rapprochement que nous avons
avec un bd à ça c'est le premier volet
l'opérateur global est le troisième
volet c'est de s'appuyer sur un grand
groupe industriel qui avaient des acquis
et numéro un en europe à vocation
internationale qui nous apportera autant
que de besoin à l'avenir les soutien
technologique dont nous aurons besoin
voire le soutien financier nous
efforçons de plus en plus de faire
croître la valeur ajoutée c'est-à-dire
de faire des activités de développement
de nouveaux produits faisant appel aux
nouvelles techno mais des produits
qu'ils soient génériques et qui après
peuvent se déployer dans différentes
versions donc ça il ya une augmentation
sensible de la valeur ajoutée donc merci
francis d'orvault merci et on va
rejoindre tout de suite valentin regeal
pour découvrir justement quelques
simulateur et savoir notamment comment
ils sont fabriqués
[Musique]
nous sommes avec le responsable business
development valentin régal bonjour
bonjour nicolas
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire qu'est
ce qu'on voit autour de nous alors ici
on présente des simulateurs stc et ace
au t on à la dst rx et mmp qui sont
utilisés en salle donc le mp basé sur la
3d les rixes sur la réalité augmentée et
on a plusieurs versions du stc b2m qui
donc lui fonctionne en laser donc on a
un bep deuxième sur mitrailleuse 12,7 et
un b 2e sur sniper doucette ces
différents armes qui sont utilisés par
l'armée française c'est exactement ces
différentes armes qui sont sains de
l'infanterie française devant nous un
système des simulateurs de tir missiles
antichars et même pc ça exactement elle
se tait donc ainsi un simulateurs
d'entraînement ou tire donc un système
qui est utilisé en intérieur qui aide le
tireur à s'approprier le système à
apprendre à faire des tirs et à
maintenir ses compétences dans le temps
comment ça fonctionne concrètement alors
comment ça fonctionne
on a ce faux postes de tir qui a une
reproduction du vrai poste de tir la
même paix dans lequel on a intégré
toutes les ja chem toutes les interfaces
qui sont en contact avec le tireur donc
on a la vraie bonne êtes les vrais
systèmes livrés il est vrai les vrais
buts le web ou tonique relié à un pc qui
vivent à gérer un environnement 3d
envoyé dans l'oeuf au poste de tir et
qui permet aux tireurs d'avoir
l'impression d'utiliser un vrai système
dans un vrai un terrain 3d fait un petit
essai on va faire un petit essai
[Musique]
on va l'essayer concrètement combien de
personnes travaillent autour de ce
système
et puis quel métier en retrouve alors on
a eu une bonne dizaine de personnes dans
l'équipe de développement de ce système
plus environ 5 à 10 personnes dans
l'équipe d'industrialisation et de
soutien on a du développement logiciel
mais on a surtout du développement
mécanique pour reproduire le système
d'armes intégrer les vrais partis du
système d'armes à l'intérieur
on a dû développement électronique pour
toutes les cartes d'interface et de
gestion de la boue tonique
on a de l'optronique pour tout ce qui
est intégration du micro moniteurs et
donc de ses lentilles ensuite on a des
personnes qui gèrent ce qu'on appelle
ici le dossier donc la conformité du
système
on a des chefs de projet à
l'industrialisation en bas on a des
personnes des techniciens qui vont en
fait monter le système dans une salle
grise et ensuite sur le terrain on ad on
a deux anciens militaires quittent avec
nous pour maintenir le système faire en
sorte qu'il soit toujours disponible
pour les forces vous occupez de toute la
filière
vous concevez le produit vous
l'industrialiser et puis vous assurer le
service après-vente exactement ensuite
toute la vie du système pour faire
bénéficier les forts d'une expérience
maximum autour du système être sûrs que
le système soit toujours prêt et
fonctionne nominalement vous recherchez
des compétences aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on cherche surtout des
personnes capables de développer du
logiciel que ça de l'hôte du logiciel
embarqué ou 3d et des personnes au
niveau de l'électronique numérique
merci valentin région de rien
responsable business development chez
j'ai d é simulation et le sky échos se
poursuit ils étaient quatre mille six
cent trente neuf personnes à avoir
bénéficié du statut étudiant
entrepreneur en france en 2010 9 d'après
le ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
parmi eux elliott passe-temps marinoni
il a fabriqué des t-shirts à base de
coton bio et de matières recyclées une
marque baptisée vilain canard un projet
suivi par patrick jane eyre le référent
entrepreneuriat à lui les sqc le
business sky avec elliot passe-temps
marinoni et patrick l'inter
patrick jouin terre je suis professeur
associé à paris saclay l'université
versailles saint quentin et plus
particulièrement en charge de
l'entrepreneuriat étudiant
[Musique]
je m'appelle elliott pasta marinoni je
suis étudiant en troisième année de
licence de gestion
il ya eu de versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
j'ai créé vilain canard donc en 2016
avec mon ami associé martin pigeon est
aujourd'hui j'occupe la fonction de
directeur général
[Musique]
un cadavre aujourd'hui c'est un concept
qu'on cherche a décliné en plusieurs
branches on a une branche atelier on a
une branche événementiel qu'on appelle
le club puis d'un canard à elliott c'est
un projet particulièrement original sur
à la fois la mode mais la mode éco
responsable on a vraiment commencé à
développer une conscience éco
responsable une conscience locker avec
toute une gamme de t-shirts qui viennent
de sortir avec nos campagnes ulule de
pré vente qui a eu beaucoup de succès
puisqu'il visait au moins une centaine
de commandes disant nombre de 300 je
suis accompagné notamment par monsieur
patrick jr qui m'aident à développer mon
projet et à le structurer
c'est intéressant de le voir mais a
chuté petit à petit à la fois sur le
logo sur la communication sur le
marketing et réseau
ça doit vraiment être de l'aide et du
coaching personnalisé lyndon de super
conseil comment sortir un nouveau
produit comment je vais les finances et
comment je vais m'appuyer aussi sur des
influenceurs dans le monde très exigeant
du surf international de
l'écoresponsabilité de l'environnement
et au fur et à mesure des choses
notamment 20 grâce à monsieur l'inter on
a réfléchi on a brain-storming on s'est
posé des questions et aujourd'hui on en
est là
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile à bientôt sur tv 60
minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]